okay we all know that Jeb Bush was
trounced by Trump in the GOP primaries
couldn't win his home state but he still
can't figure out why why did Donald
Trump win or even who's leading the
party well Jim resurfaced in a USA Today
interview this afternoon we actually ran
into him earlier tonight it's a little
uncomfortable and he's again lashing out
at the president well to compare and
contrast this interview with the
president's performance at Davos we're
joined by Fox News contributor but I'm
on Arroyo I like that my mom yes I
remember my Spanish tonight okay this
was Jeb Bush today USA Today interviewed
him let's watch well it has to be the
president
he's naked no he's not he doesn't he
doesn't represent I don't think he's a
traditional conservative what was he
confused by the question well he was the
leader of the party and I can't imagine
why he got the nickname low-energy
here's my here's my first question
Wow why are they even talking to Jeb
Bush now is Carly Fiorina and and
Governor Gilmore going to make an
appearance next I mean what are the
qualifications the president is
triumphing at Davos and we're but
they're interviewing poor chip and this
is part of the reason he lost and it's
okay we saw him tonight
he's a gentleman a school choice
advocate all right tell me okay that
he's not really good at that but he's
mean he's mean to trumpet but look at
the optics he's sitting in a middle
school library on a child's chair and he
looks like he's being so filleted the
principal it's very say okay now Trump
would never alone so no no no so compare
and contrast that with well Donald Trump
today I think we're doing a very special
job and I really believe it was time and
it was time to do that job because I
don't think the United States would have
done very well if it went through four
or eight more years of regulation and
really a very anti business group of
people in one year we've cut more
regulations in my administration than
any other administration in for eight or
sixteen years in the one case and we
have a ways to go I mean we're probably
50% done you see him dominating he did
this all a few days he was at Dulles he
dominated it a little bit but I kind of
like the soldier and in command of the
of the the material this this okay
you're comparing poor Jeb Bush in a
middle school library to Donald Trump
with all the glow globes billionaires
that's not exactly an equal playing
field
okay one more this is Jeb Bush on
Trump's rhetoric Oh
I don't think he will succeed if he
continues on this path I just don't see
a good outcome with all of the all the
rhetoric all the hateful comments but
that ultimately is going to drag down
the positive things that that he and his
team are doing David Brooks and why
would he David Brown why does he do this
before midterms the fact is Jeb Bush was
saying Billy Bush was going to kill the
president Trump
they said that judge curial comments
were going to kill him he rose and won
the party support him out he went he
went on to say he needs to Trump needs
to focus on on creating income that's
rising for Americans and keeping America
what is he badly Jeb Bush at this point
is like Elton John and Cher
they keep announcing the retirement but
they won't go away so I'm waiting for
the Jim Gilmore and George Pataki
interviews from USA Today
I guess those gripping of primary
candidates that also lost nervous call
you low-energy
my mom won't be low energy Oh like I'm
never doing an interview in a middle
school library never never on those low
chair no that's not good Harry Potter no
no never works